vous autour de la table que ce soit
fille ou garçon est ce que vous avez
déjà eu dû affronter un cas de
harcèlement sexuel dans votre métier
dans le cadre de votre travail même
concédé mais en télévision vous
christine oui à plusieurs reprises mois
à plusieurs reprises sa sny a réalisé
comment plusieurs plusieurs reprises au
travail
je me rappelle quand j'étais journaliste
presse écrite dans un magazine de de
tourisme et j'arrivais tous les matins
je venais de commencer je premier jour
j'arrive le patro très sympa avec moi me
touche un peu voilà tu tu sens que c'est
un peu bizarre mais bon je dis bon c'est
pas grave ça va passer le lendemain
matin à la première heure et vient
derrière son ordinateur te passe encore
la main sur l'épaule caresse tu te dis
mais quand même toit c'est un peu gênant
le troisième jour tu arrives ya un mot
tu tapes sur ton ordi il ya un mot doux
sur ton ordinateur
il revient encore derrière les barreaux
lugano mais bien relou et puis l'as tu
fais pas tu te dis que tu viens
travailler pour avoir quelle réaction
vous essayez de mabiala dans ma réaction
a été très clair - troisième jour ce que
j'ai vu à la fois le mot sur
l'ordinateur et encore les câlins voilà
que je n'avais pas demandé
je me suis levé je suis parti sans
salaire et je ne suis plus jamais plus
jamais on ne l'a plus jamais à la plus
jeune j'ai pas été payés ni quoi que ce
soit mais je suis parti parce qu'on
vient travailler pour être payés on
vient pas travailler pour baiser mais
leur donnez moi l'expression merci je
suis méchant de trois étages et au fait
quid des façons je ne le vois pas voilà
je conduis clip ou es ce que vous avez
eu des lorsque j'étais plus jeune
j'étais assistant d'un photographe
thomas studio à paris et en fait il
s'est avéré que sept personnes avaient
connecter mon iphone sur le chic si je
connais pas trop tout ça mais à icloud
club sur son ordinateur est en fait tous
les soirs il lisait tous mes messages
toute la nuit de tous nos rosés à mes
copines et tout et puis le lendemain
user comme si elle de rien n'était à
longueur de journée montré des photos de
ses ex il me dit regarde tu lui
ressemble et tout ça a duré comme ça
pendant peut-être six mois et puis un
jour j'ai pété les plombs je me suis dit
bas mais il va essayer de voir des
choses avec vous il était lourd ou pas
il était lourd au point de tous les
jours me montrer des photos de femmes
avec des gros nichons à me dire voilà il
est bien
tu serais comme elle voilà le soir ils
étaient mes messages et en plus je
disais des horreurs sur lui à mes
copines non pour que le lendemain écrit
saint girons jours comme si de rien
était ce qu'il y avait un problème mais
moi je vais même problème avec de
l'hormone est ce qu'il peut y avoir à
harcèlement sans agression c'est à dire
en l'occurrence qu'il est lourd mais il
n'a jamais jamais il a jamais eu un
geste déplacé
ça dépend comment là comment la jeune
fille ressemble à celle à laquelle il a
ressenti comme une agression
le soir il me retenais par exemple ah
ouais normalement je suis terminée vers
19 heures épuisé non mais encore un truc
à faire
ça a duré jusqu'à 23h par le boulet
géraldine bloch dans le grand jeu de la
situation du désir de la sexualité ouais
moi dans ma carrière de mannequin
évidemment il ya eu des lourds à des
prédateurs mais des harceleurs light
à ce moment là ben moi je la faisais
très vite comprendre comme christine
peut-être moins cinq jours en cinq
minutes que c'était même pas la peine
s'il a eu des gros ce qu'il ya eu des
gros loi ce cas quelqu'un qui a été
confrontée vous réponds bah je vous jure
c'est nice apparaît du nerf vague un
gardien d'immeuble rue caumartin dans la
rotation mais non attendez là on va se
reposer 5 minutes il est dit oui mais
elle a commencé par mettre son numéro de
téléphone sur les six glaces du camion
je n'allais pas rappelés chez virer ça
j'ai dit oh bruno bono c'est le barman
j'y tiens le bois garde c'est quoi ce
délire une liste elle a gardé un allant
qui vivent sur toi le lendemain des
fleurs sur les suit la gc10 lui qui a
l'art est là et un jour je me je remonte
dans quinze ans que moi je fais un pas
mais porte quand je livre je livrais je
descends jours il est mignon elle est
montée sur le cas d'un côté à la casse
et déjà vu j'avais mis des verts ale
montant vous côté passager elle m'a dit
je viens avec toi je fais des sens je me
suis pris la tête avec elle alors au
moins 10 minutes mais je vous jure que
c'est vrai vous ne pas descendre du
camion est ce que ça c'est du
harcèlement c'est pas méchant ça moi je
vis dans ce sens là mais j'ai pas dit ça
va forcément aller moi dans le travail
comme toutes les femmes alors 17 et 55
ans entre même un peu plus on a été tout
harceler abandonnant ce qui s'est passé
tout le plus pénible pour moi c'est
quand j'étais étudiant à paris et que
j'étais dans un petit hôtel boulevard
murat et toutes les nuits le mec rentrer
dans ma chambre
quoi et ça je voudrais que quand vous
vous accrochez ou le sit in comme en
iran khodro souligné qu'il avait un pass
toutes les nuits rentrais dans ma
chambre j'ai pas fallu sortir
il avait un pneu toutes les chalets
travail dans lequel il travaille dans le
changer d'hôtel parce qu'il était
pratiqué des prénoms l'école et tout et
tout et moi je suis très bien élevé tant
que c'est pas quelqu'un qui gifle et où
je m'en sortais en boutade et où quinze
jours c'est mon mari qui l'a chopé il
était l'âme mais qui savait pas y croyez
que c'est moi donc il est revenu vers le
lien que comme dans les films et non
cette affaire mais c'est tout lâche me
regarde et il est rentré il ressortait
dans quoi je faisais semblant de dormir
mais c'est clair c'est une autre
histoire
bonjour temps dans un cv tu veux bosser
dans une chaîne là une personnalité te
reçois et au bout de cinq minutes
franchement la personnalité sort son
sexe
mais nous sommes en progrès parce que
j'étais spectateur qui l'ont rejoint
donc vous avez jeunes mais j'avais voulu
travailler dans une chaîne
vous avez rencontré ou un animateur à
quelqu'un ou une personnalité quand il
passe a été connue oui et donc elle vous
a dit bonjour et la non moins en moins
de 3 minutes 30
ballack est ce qu'il a fait alors à
nantes il a sorti son sexe en disant
wall ag amoureux de vous voilà regarder
les faits que vous me faites et je dis
pardon excusez moi il ya mon mari qui
m'attend bas et honnêtement
franchement je suis parti en courant en
me disant qu'il n'y aurait jamais eu le
job
ah bah finalement j'ai eu quand même
j'étais très contente d'avoir résisté
non mais les histoires comme ça mais les
téléspectateurs doivent vraie révélation